course often underestimated or seen as
beginner stuff but man they are awesome
and so versatile and so important I put
together a list of five great tricks to
turn your everyday stuff into epic and
sweet sounding goodness let's jump right
in here's number one the power cord
trick of course the most legendary court
for guitar the power cord we can turn it
into something beautiful we probably all
know something like this see power port
T power chord e power chord but we can
make it so much more epic our typical
power chord has a root C in this case
and v that's why we write down a power
chord as a v like C 5 that means a power
chord because it's only the root and a
fifth but there's also the octave in the
court in this case C again g string fret
5 but that octave really doesn't do too
much to the sound
you see there's not much of a difference
so let's remove it and put it back one
string lower now we still have that same
power cord but we add the major third to
the court so this is basically just a
major chord and this sounds a little
more melodic but still has the oomph and
the power of that power chord
and on D we do the same so the power
cord let's remove our pinky put it back
over there for seven string to 2 D and
on e we basically do the same but did
this we turn it into a minor chord so we
use our middle finger on fret 8 so now
we've got this
[Music]
[Applause]
awesome and you can do that with every
power cord you can think of experiment
with major or minor or even inversions
man that options are based limitless
so let's yeah
[Music]
sweet next up this trick is just great
for playing open chords so basically you
can use it all the time right say we
play a C and a D chord
[Music]
okay that sounds it sounds pretty weak
right let's fatten it up a little bit so
there's one giant massive string that's
unused right now and that's the low E so
just smack that v as a base note
underneath that C chord so instead of C
we move our ring finger to the G put
back our pinky and
[Music]
how fat does that sound right that low E
string is a really big chunk of your
sound potential and if you're miss out
that string so much goes missing so why
not just use it of course there's a
place for everything but oftentimes it
sounds really cool so why not do the
same for D so if you play this chord
like C
if you just slide up two frets
Wow so good
[Applause]
[Music]
but also with playing chords like f C
and G we can do the same when you play
the F chord compared to the G G just
sounds so much fatter because it uses
all six strings so let's play like this
[Music]
[Applause]
C major seven over G that's just
you just so love these little more
intricate sounding and if you ask me
more nuance we carefully select our
voicing to match the next or the
previous chord and we can take it even
further
[Music]
[Applause]
sweet
next up when you discover this you just
can't go back and it's the open string
Hank
so here's four quarts
[Music]
well you know it but what if I told you
we can turn it into this
[Music]
[Applause]
where are the tissues you might ask
just keep the top two strings open and
let them ring out through every chord
and sometimes you've got to fit a little
bit with your hands to make sure that
yeah the shape fits the chord but it's
always very rewarding and it's really
worth it
and the cool thing is we just played in
the key of E quartz B c-sharp minor G
sharp minor a F sharp minor we can use
the same technique in any key so C is a
very different key than E so we can use
like yeah that's the C major seventh
again great chord and then to D
beautiful
you don't even have to know the name of
the court just listen and use your ears
and it sounds great
[Music]
[Applause]
super versatile and my tip is to just to
try to use them and any key any chord
progression you like and just listen if
it sounds good trust your ears they are
super handy these things what you
discover might just amaze you
next up the G shape trick okay
here is something that baffles me and I
see so few people this is I wonder if
the trick is just too hard or just
people don't know about it let me
explain
so here's free chords just basic chords
D minor C and B flat nothing too special
and I think everyone will pick one of
these voicings just like when I showed
you G minor B flat or over here D minor
so there's always a gap in between the
chords when shifting between the one or
the other because you just have to move
all frets to a new position so there's
always a gap in between but the way I
like to do it D minor
[Applause]
did you hear that one more time same
course
did you hear that the switch from D
minor to C was way more fluent like this
so this is basically the G shape of a
silly cord coming from yes the G major
chord so this is what I played if I
shift it down to a G chord this is
basically and I move it up to C so I'm
playing the root note with my pinky C
and the index finger bars fret 5 on the
D G and B string and I omit the a and
the high E string and that's the chord
and sometimes it's so much fun to play
just a great way to change between these
chords so this way we can hold down
position find with our index finger so
we create a nice and smooth transition
[Music]
you see it's just a super handy
courtship and I seldom leacy folks use
it so start playing it attitude
vocabulary and congratulations you just
became a better guitarist before we go
to the last tip let's just quickly talk
about becoming a better guitar player if
what I've been explaining goes a little
bit too fast for you or over your head I
suggest checking out learn practice play
that's my guitar course I designed for
beginners starting from the basics and
but you want to know more and dive
deeper into the matter next level
playing my second external course will
be right up your alley it's a little
more intermediate bass guitar course
talking about chords solos techniques
theory and all kinds of interesting
stuff so I put my soul and my heart into
both so it would be amazing if you check
it out and support a channel that way
anyway thanks for the sponsor segment
Paul let's go to the last tip number 5
so we talked about open strings right
but that's combined with open chords
because there's so much we can get out
of these just simple basic open chord
shapes just slide them up here's a few
examples so let's start with the D chord
that sounds great if he moved it to
position five for example
[Music]
you see I also moved to 7 just D shape
move it up to 5 to 7 and 4 is also
it's just a great way to create some
eerie or some strange sounding course
because it's not super theoretically
chosen you but you can just you know you
can just again trust your ears sounds
like it being floating right so another
great court for this is a minor can go
to position six
[Music]
it sounds to a file war we can do the
same with E to school
[Music]
[Applause]
just grab your cord and slide it up see
[Music]
[Applause]
so much fun a minor you can just pick
everything
[Music]
No so now we gotta trust our ears and
say Paul you're going too far stop this
this is not a good core
oh and one more thing I just thought it
was like when you play a power chord
just a root and a fifth on the a string
[Music]
that's a great fun for sliding up and
down as well
[Music]
[Applause]
how good does this guitar sound so to
recap basically every open chord there's
a cool spot where you can play it and it
just sounds great and moody and awesome
for everyday use and you just can't be
too generous with it just throw it on
everything so if one of these tips might
help you get a better guitar player just
pay back a little bit by just gently
hitting that like button it means a lot
to me it's free for you so why not and
also super things will be commenting or
subscribing to the channel and even
beyond that there's my patreon page
which which you can check out and that's
basically the end of this video every
one today and I hope to see you next
time Cheers
[Music]